I know this just a way in which I
changed my study habits it was different
my math skills went up completely
especially with my SATs
I was more social in school I got more
involved in things cuz I felt like I had
more confidence in myself I can do
things because I went to a program and I
did really well here
I'm dr. Amy burger I love that woman
she's so great she was an assistant for
the bio lab that we did here really like
helps you understand what you're doing
because in science it's just like you
can't just get something one saying you
think you're gonna understand it you
have to like apply it continuously
I haven't contact with her you know
before I came here and she helped me
plan out my schedule and even like
schools I was applying to and she gave
recommendations and just like having a
person to talk to she was so great in
that aspect
and a lot of kids they feel like telling
if I did I'm good enough for certain
programs and I feel like this is a
program that it makes you feel better
about yourself by the time you leave
you're not the same person that you came
in as and it's great just seeing that
growth in yourself